[Music]
how much are we willing to forgive when
we really like a person Peter Parker's a
normal guy so grounded despite his
superpowers he has an innate likability
that draws me towards him
I love his sarcastic insults as he
punches enemies and wry observations as
he swings through the city I never get
to sightsee he's fun but he also lacks
restraint beating the stuffing out of
ordinary criminals seems a bit excessive
no and then the amazing spider-man 2 he
bugs cell phone towers for his own
revenge so is he a good guy or just
another powerful man who sets his own
rules and that question of forgiveness
extends to the action - I like
spider-man and is that a snappy best in
this latest adventure I wanted to spend
time with him hear him belt out insults
while smacking down his evil minded
folks but should I forgive the game's
problems just because I find the main
character so endearing it's not an easy
question at times I did overlook the
swirling camera that struggles to
properly frame the action and the sloppy
locomotion as I swung across Manhattan
after all why get hung up on the finicky
movement when it feels so freeing to
soar above the traffic below but at the
hours flew by the problems that came
more noticeable the combat is so simple
more reliant on quick time button
presses than actual skill that it soon
became tiresome to knock my opponents
heads in and similar to what we've seen
in the Batman Arkham series only even
more rudimentary than the Dark Knight's
fisticuffs and without the bone crushing
impact that makes you cringe
[Music]
Fite require a little more than slamming
on attack and dodging when enemies glow
red and I need more depth in my super
heroic conquests the side missions also
require their fair share of forgiveness
Manhattan is a crime-ridden City where
citizens are confronted early and often
by the criminal underbelly spire man
must stop these heinous acts to keep his
hero level high so you're compelled to
stop high-speed chases and robberies
before the city turns against you it's a
fine idea because spider-man should
strive for the greater good but even
this simple idea falters for one the
side missions themselves aren't
interesting rescuing people from
smoke-filled buildings highlights how
clunky the game is and enclosed spaces
and fighting regular enemies is too easy
to be interesting the punishment system
wasn't a real that turns either what did
I care people didn't like me sure a task
force would hunt me down but it was easy
enough to avoid their strikes plus the
story missions pitted me as the villain
anyway
no matter how much good I accomplished
so the side missions are a bust
still if not like the amazing spider-man
2 lacks fonts
I did enjoy swinging through the city
there are comic book pages and posters
sprinkled throughout and even though I
don't read comic books in real life it
was cool to check out one in Stanley
shop it's just a world I want to exist
in to spend time with spider-man sees
various suits and meet as many members
the amazing spider-man 2 is worse
failing is that it's expected we've seen
countless open-world games in this
manner including many already starring
spider-man sort of Warne surprises but
it's all a man of your forgiveness
spider-man is so likable that it's
possible to overlook the simplicity of
the combat and the tedium of the side
missions
there's nothing majorly wrong with the
game after all this is not a heck of a
lot right with it either
[Music]